the Kia is a particularly intelligent
species of parrot from New Zealand now
research suggests that these birds might
be smarter than anyone expected even up
performing monkeys in some tasks these
care can use probabilities to predict
which hand a black token is most likely
to be in based on where the token is
picked from and on who is doing the
picking even combining information from
different contexts the key are great fun
to work with they are some of the most
intelligent Birds I've ever met and they
all have amazing personalities
amalia bass das has been working with
Kea trying to find out whether they
could predict uncertain future events
could they understand the events that
happened with incomplete information
could they fill in the gaps so if you
imagine that I'm placing my hand into a
jar with mostly blue candies and a few
yellow candies and I take something from
that jar but you can't see what's in my
hand you might guess that I've taken a
blue candy and we wanted to see if you
could do the same thing
a group of captive Kea were taught the
black tokens and only black tokens could
be exchanged for food they then saw an
experimenter take tokens from two jars
without being able to see what was in
each hand
they chose a hand by tapping on it to
get the token inside in the first
experiment the Kea almost always
preferred the jar with the highest
proportion of black tokens even when the
actual number of black tokens in each
was the same this suggests they were
choosing the hand based on the
probability of it containing a black
token something only previously seen in
great apes
a second experiment showed they could
even take into account a barrier in the
middle of the jar looking for the jars
with the highest proportion of black
tokens in the top section and ignoring
the rest so Kia have a complex social
structure where many individuals can
live in a group and they come and go as
they please and that means they need to
remember the identities of multiple
individuals and they have to interact
with multiple individuals and of course
they need to remember all these
interactions so we wanted to see whether
Kia could understand that experimenters
have biases or preferences when they
make their selections for example one
person might select a yellow candy even
when the yellow candy is in the minority
and another might select a yellow candy
when they're in the majority and what we
can assume from that is that the person
who took yellow candy when it wasn't the
minority actually prefers yellow candies
to blue candies the third part of the
experiment tested their social skills
the birds were shown to humans taking
tokens from a jar one person looked into
the jar and deliberately picked one of
very few black tokens when later offered
a choice of experimenters the Kea
remembered this person and their
apparent preference for black tokens we
were very surprised to find that Kea can
use social cues even from humans to make
these judgments here we're looking at
the biased experimenter understanding
that they had a bias or a preference for
a particular type of token and then
selecting this person a test when both
experimenters have the same populations
of tokens reading human social cues like
this and remembering information about
individuals to use when making
predictions is another ability that so
far only been shown in great apes here
look very intelligent and they behave
very intelligently I just didn't expect
them to perform quite as well as
chimpanzees do this experiment marks the
first evidence that birds can make
predictions about future events using
probabilities and that they can combine
information from different contexts to
make those predictions I can't wait to
see what he'll do next because they they
keep surprising us so I can't wait to
see what the next
step ring okay you plankton can you okay
just a little bit thank you can you move
please stand up the tab